Transcription: eric vautier
(Applaudissements)
(Chuchote)
(Rires)
Je plaisante...
L'avenir de l'humanité
n'est plus entre ses mains.
n'est plus entre ses mains,
mais entre celles
d'intelligences artificielles
que nous avons créées
sans nous en rendre compte.
Des parasites. Géants. Mondiaux.
Ça va ? (Rires)
Ça va, vous passez une bonne soirée ?
Je sais que pour un début de dernier talk,
ça casse un peu l'ambiance.
À la fin ça finit bien,
ne vous inquiétez pas.
Je suis Jasmin, et vous ?
Vous pouvez répondre, c'est un talk !
(Rires)
I don't make a speech,
we have a talk !
Ce n'est pas du tout la même chose !
Déjà qu'on n'a que 18 minutes
pour changer le monde...
Ceci dit, ça veut dire qu'on est
dans le thème de la soirée :
bouger les lignes. (Rires)
18 minutes...
On peut bien en perdre une ensemble, non ?
(Rires)
Tenez, puisqu'on va se quitter...
Disons-nous au revoir.
Allez-y. Je vais montrer l'exemple.
Au revoir, Jasmin, coach d'intér...
Allez-y, dites-vous au revoir !
Surtout aux gens à qui vous avez dit
bonjour tout à l'heure.
Donc vos...
C'est pour voir si
vous avez retenu les noms,
sans regarder les badges !
S'il vous plaît, on se dit au revoir,
tout le monde se dit au revoir.
N'ayez pas peur !
Dites-vous au revoir.
On se dit au revoir, voilà.
Tenez, je fais la bise là.
Faites passer, sinon
ça va être un petit peu long.
Je fais la bise.
Palpez-vous !
Palpez-vous, relâchez les tensions !
Palpez la personne qui est devant,
n'ayez pas peur.
On a eu le temps de faire connaissance.
Voilà, tout le monde s'est bien palpé ?
Bien, reprenons.
On a quand même un petit peu de travail
et plus que 16 minutes.
Des intelligences artificielles président
aujourd'hui à nos destinées,
ainsi qu'à nos vies quotidiennes.
Internet.
Internet peut être considéré
comme un super organisme,
ayant une vie autonome, s'étant propagé
au-delà des frontières, des religions,
des cultures, et des régimes politiques.
L'économie de marché, la finance, sont
également des super organismes artificiels
qui ont une vie autonome.
Nous pouvons y participer,
nous pouvons jouer avec,
nous pouvons les influencer,
surfer, couler,
mais personne aujourd'hui ne peut agir
sur leur nature, sur leur existence.
Demandez d'ailleurs aux
divers gouvernements de votre choix.
La seule chose que nous pouvons faire,
c'est de participer à leur développement,
les nourrir.
Une des conséquences de cela,
parce que si nous ne le faisons pas,
elles se développent d'elles-mêmes,
n'est-ce pas ?
Ailleurs, autrement, sans nous.
Donc, une des conséquences de cela,
c'est que nous sommes sollicités,
chacun de nous, quotidiennement,
pour être au top,
dans notre vie professionnelle,
notre vie personnelle,
notre vie sociale, notre vie familiale,
affective, citoyenne, sexuelle,
l'éducation, l'alimentation,
le tri des déchets, -20% sur les vacances,
il faut que j'envoie le devis,
sans compter mes points retraite,
rappeler mamie, t'as vu l'heure,
tu vois bien que je suis au téléphone.
Et puis aussi, finir le devis
avant lundi, je l'ai déjà dit,
quel temps pourri,
envoyer le dossier Bouchard,
racheter des mouchoirs,
tout en ayant un avis sur
les conditions de vie au Bhoutan !
(Rires)
Qui ne s'est pas rasé
le matin en se disant :
« Mais je ne vais jamais réussir
à tout faire aujourd'hui ! »
N'est-ce pas, Madame ?
(Rires)
Mais, je pense...
Vous avez raison, vous avez raison,
mais je pense qu'il faut
que nous cessions
de nous considérer comme des individus,
des êtres humains.
Car si ces entreprises deviennent
des organismes vivants,
devenons, chacun de nous,
des entreprises individuelles !
De véritables entreprises organiques,
compétitives, performantes,
avec une stratégie claire,
un marketing structuré,
une équipe motivée et un produit
sans cesse en renouvellement !
Nous-mêmes.
L'Inside Green Management (Rires)
aide l'individu à devenir une entreprise.
Si je décide de devenir
un Inside Green Manager,
ça veut dire que je décide de m'appliquer
le triple A sur ma vie !
(Rires)
Audace ! Authenticité !
Accomplissement ! Amour... (Rires)
Avec l'Inside Green Management,
ensemble, dès aujourd'hui,
plantons les racines de dedans le futur.
(Rires)
Et c'est pour cela que votre Talk
est certifié ISO 14001.
Et c'est pour cela qu'acquérir
l'Inside Green Management
ne se fait pas comme ça !
Il y a une méthode ! A process !
Ein Protokoll !
Un tequila rápido por favor !
Hé oui ! (Applaudissements)
Hé oui, une méthode !
Mesdames et Messieurs si nous voulons
changer le monde, il est nécessaire
d'en utiliser les règles.
Comme le dit d'ailleurs si bien l'adage :
si tu veux détourner un avion,
il faut monter dedans.
(Rires)
Je vous laisse avec
ce fameux proverbe taliban.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
J'ai pu expérimenter que pour entrer dans
le mode de pensée Inside Green Management,
il est toujours nécessaire
de passer par une phase
d'échauffement psycho-émotionnel
de groupe.
Un E.P.E.D.G.
Ein E.P.E.D.G.
Una cerveza pronto, pronto.
(Rires)
C'est un exercice, un module
devrais-je dire,
destiné à apprendre à
s'exprimer en public,
avec notre outil
de communication premier,
notre instrument de travail : notre corps.
Alors, je vous propose...
- bonsoir proposition -
ensemble ce soir d'expérimenter
un tout petit EPEDG. Vous voulez bien ?
Oui ?
Public : Oui.
JCG : C'est vrai que, si spontanément,
vous me répondez : « Oui Jasmin »...
Public : Oui Jasmin !
JCG : Vous me renforcez dans la confiance
dans mon entreprise.
(Rires)
Vous voulez bien ?
Public : Oui, Jasmin !
JCG : Merci.
On peut commencer simplement
avec une articulation.
On va faire ça en musique.
On peut avoir un petit peu de musique ?
(Musique)
Allez-y ! Faites-le pour vous !
C'est un exercice personnel.
C'est un exercice personnel,
mais de groupe.
On ne copie pas sur son voisin.
Il n'y a pas de bien, pas de mal !
On fait ce qu'on veut, on fait juste
attention à ne pas blesser ses voisins.
Faites-le pour vous, faites-le pour vous.
Madame, si vous avez peur
d'être ridicule, regardez-moi.
Et voilà ça relâche !
Pensez-y lundi matin.
Comme ça, on arrive à
une petite réunion de travail...
Tout de suite ça relâche les tensions !
Moi j'adore faire ça.
Ceux qui ne savent pas quoi faire,
on peut se palper la pulpe.
Allez, on se palpe la pulpe,
s'il vous plaît !
On se palpe la pulpe là-bas !
Monsieur, si vous vous palpez la pulpe
les mains dans les poches,
vous allez vous faire très mal.
Voilà, très bien.
Allez on se palpe la pulpe.
Et on se palpe la palme.
Je vous vois.
Et on se palpe l'autre palme
avec la pulpe sus-décrite.
Et les pulpes !
Et les palmes.
Et si ça va trop vite, Monsieur,
on peut se palper le pouls.
Et les pulpes.
Et les palmes.
Et les pulpes et les pulpes
et les palmes.
Et les palmes et les pulpes.
Et les pulpes et les palmes
et les pulpes et les palmes et le pouls
et les palmes et les pulpes et -
suivez s'il vous plaît !
Et les pulpes et les palmes
et les pulpes et le pouls
et le pouls et les poux
et les poils et les genoux
et les palmes et les genoux
et les poux
et les poils et les palmes
et les palmes et les palmes et les palmes
et les palmes et les palmes !
(Applaudissements)
Très bien ! Très bien, on peut arrêter.
Très bon groupe !
(Rires)
Vous savez, c'est avec un esprit
tel que celui-là que vous allez m'aider
à vous aider à devenir de vrais
Inside Green Managers !
Ça, en tout cas, c'est mon taf !
It's my job.
C'est mon travail.
Alors, connaître son outil de travail,
c'est nécessaire,
mais ce n'est pas suffisant.
Il faut savoir comment l'utiliser,
vers où l'utiliser,
dans quel secteur
il est le plus approprié.
Souvent, on a besoin de faire
un grand audit interne.
Je vous propose...
- bonsoir proposition -
pour ce grand audit ensemble ce soir,
de se connecter à son mammifère intime.
(Rires)
Vous voulez bien ?
Public : Oui Jasmin !
Oui Jasmin !
JCG : Arrêtez...
(Rires)
Bon, très bien !
On laisse travailler un petit peu
son bureau recherche et développement.
Et on applique tout de suite
ce qu'on a appris en EPEDG.
Et on laisse venir
le ou les mammifères intimes,
qui viennent ! (Cris d'oiseau)
Surtout (Aboiement) pas de jugement
entre nous (Bruitage)
Ce qu'il est important de se rappeler,
(Divers cris d'animaux)
c'est ce que nous allons faire
(Singe) ensemble.
(Divers bruitages)
C'est vrai, on nous dit tellement
(Bruitages)
Vous n'imaginez pas tout
ce qu'on peut faire pour vous.
(Bruitages)
Nous travaillons nuit et jour pour vous.
Notre plus belle destination, c'est vous.
Notre plus beau voyage, c'est vous.
D'ailleurs, si je suis élu,
c'est pour vous.
Allez, s'il vous plaît, (Cri du paon)
faites-le pour vous.
(Caquètement) Allez, chacun pour soi.
Il y a quelque chose là !
Il est important de faire venir
son mammifère intime,
mais il faut quand même garder
le contrôle des opérations,
sinon ça devient n'importe quoi !
(Divers cris d'animaux)
Allez-y, faites-le pour vous !
(Rires)
Allez-y, s'il vous plaît !
Vous en avez de très belles !
Allez-y, continuez !
Je veux bien qu'on me rebranche.
(Aboiements)
(Applaudissements)
Je vois qu'il y en a qui font la carpe.
(Rires)
(Caquètements)
Bon, je n'y arrive pas !
Allez-y, on fait les animaux de la ferme,
allez-y.
(Divers cris d'animaux)
Attendez, attendez ! Attendez.
Non, je vois qu'il y en a qui travaillent
pour d'autres.
Mesdames et Messieurs, il faut partir
du principe que si tout le monde le fait,
personne n'est ridicule !
Vous avez vu la danse tout à l'heure.
Allez on fait les animaux de la ferme !
(Divers cris d'animaux)
Voilà ! (Son de cloche)
Allez Bijou ! (Cris)
C'est très bien !
C'est très bien, c'est très bien !
Mais je réponds d'ores et déjà
à certaines des questions que je reçois :
oui, mon mammifère intime
peut être un dindon.
(Rires)
Oui, il peut être une poule.
Come on, think different !
(Rires)
Si on n'arrive pas à penser différemment,
comment voulez-vous
que nous débroussaillions
de nouvelles pistes ?
Que nous développions
de nouvelles cultures ?
Enfin, que nous allions vers
des secteurs plus éloignés de nous !
Le végétal !
Le végétal...
Je vous propose...
- bonsoir proposition -
non pas de faire pousser ou fleurir
votre légume intime
mais plutôt quelque chose
de plus collectif,
comme un marché commun,
quelque chose de...
Comme une grande forêt solidaire, unisexe,
un truc fraternel...
Un champ de blé !
Vous voulez bien ?
Public : Oui Jasmin !
JCG : Il y en a deux qui suivent.
S'il vous plaît, on vous a dit
une méthode, quand même.
Allez, allez ! Puisqu'on va tous faire
la même chose,
je vais quand même vous montrer
un peu de théorie.
L'épi de blé.
L'épi de blé, vous avez la tige
en elle-même.
Vous avez l'épi de l'épi.
De part et d'autre partent des barbules.
Et l'épi de blé est naturellement heureux.
(Rires)
Allez tout le monde en épi de blé !
Tout le monde en épi de blé.
Tout le monde en épi de blé là-bas !
Voilà, très bien.
Très bien.
Et on fait l'épi de blé dans le vent.
Elle regarde la retransmission webcam ?
C'est ça, tu fais quoi ? La souche ?
On fait l'épi de blé, allez, on ondule,
petit champ de blé.
Ondulez dans le vent.
On peut caresser son petit frère,
sa petite sœur, épis de blé.
On sent l'envie d'enlever ses vêtements
qui se fait de plus en plus forte !
(Rires)
En épi de blé là-haut !
On n'a pas moissonné encore,
qu'est-ce que tu fais ?
L'épeautre ?
Voilà ! Oui Monsieur, sous le soleil,
on sent son petit épi
qui devient tout ferme !
(Rires)
Attendez ! Tout le monde en champ
de blé là, tout le monde en champ de blé.
C'est très très important,
s'il vous plaît.
C'est encore 10 secondes.
Allez-y, n'ayez pas peur, vous allez voir.
Tout le monde en champ de blé,
et c'est très important,
Mesdames et Messieurs,
surtout avec des gens
que vous ne connaissez pas,
regardez-vous les uns les autres.
(Rires)
Regardez-vous !
Regardez-vous les uns les autres.
Regardez-vous, voyez !
Observez ! Constatez !
Qu'on pousse dans une direction fertile.
Mais, Mesdames et Messieurs, pour répondre
à ces intelligences artificielles,
qui tentent de nous créer
des vies artificielles,
vous le constatez maintenant,
vous le sentez.
Indubitablement.
Vous le voyez, que
l'Inside Green Management,
ce qu'il fait à l'intérieur,
se voit à l'extérieur.
Je vous remercie !
(Applaudissements)
Merci infiniment !